vous avez vu que Pamela Anderson que
j'embrasse Pamela qui VI peut-être nous
voir bientôt d'ailleurs je suis je suis
en train de voir avec elle l'actrice
superstar d'aler Malibu de 56 ans a
décidé de ne plus se maquiller en public
et d'être naturel regardez comment elle
est apparue à la Fashion Awards elle a
fait sensation
regardez
e ouais qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
c'est formidable très honnêtement en
plus elle dit ma maquilleuse de toujours
est décédée je vois pas qui peut me
maquiller donc je m'assume au naturel
trouve ça non mais je trouve ça sublime
c'est la deuxème fois qu'elle le fait
elle dit je me sens bien dans ma peau
peu importe ce que pensent les autres je
trouve ça génialut aller jusquau bout
parce que là quand même je suis désolé
mais elle a du Botox le Botox ça part au
bout de 3 mois donc si elle a envie
d'arrêter le Botox elle peut l'arrêter
elle a de l'acide hyaluronique ça se
voit l'acide hyaluronique tu peux
l'enever pasème j'en ai plein la gueule
de
l' j'i plein la gueule juge pas que je
veux dire c'est que quand tu veux prener
le naturel faut aller jusqu'au bout tu
vois le maquillage c'est une chose
l'urinique et le Botox autant l'arrêter
aussi dans C cas elle pr pas le naturel
elle dit juste je ne veux plus me
maquiller moi je trouve qu'il faut
beaucoup non mais il faut beaucoup de
courage malgré tout quand un sex symbole
comme elle et encore un sex symbole
alors qu'elle a été tout le temps scruté
étudiée un fantasme pour la terre
entière de s'afficher comme ça à 56 ans
franchement je trouve qu'elle libère
aussi pas mal de femmes en disant voilà
je un sex symbole et aujourd'hui j'ai
juste pas envie de me maquiller je
trouve que c'est quand même elle avait
fait la fashion we de Paris déjà et
c'est c'est un mouvement qui est qu'elle
a initié mais il y a d'autres grandes
actrices qui le font maintenant qui
disent on va se montrer au naturel al
moi je ça très courageux parce que moi
par exemple suis influenceuse et du coup
je suis reconnue dans la rue quand j'ai
pas de maquillage je mets un masque
comme ça on me reconnait pas parce que
par exemple un jour jeis sorti sans
maquillage et sans masque j'ai fait une
photo avec quelqu'un et après il a mis
sur Twitter et il a dit regardeer elle
est trop moche dans la vraie vie non
c'est ça du coup bah je ça très
courageux moi j'aurais pas
é non plus moi je trouve ça moi j'adère
pas au projet je vois pas le projet quoi
c'est moi je préfère quand une femme je
suis peut-être vieux jeu j'aime bien
quand une femme se met à son avantage se
maquille pour je suis vieux jeu je vieux
jeu je même pasonnu trouve pour 56 ans
je la trouve très jolie ça m'aurait pas
comme ça c'est génial d'abord là elle
elle est très belle 5 même comme c'est
même très bien parce que maintenant elle
elle peut se balader incognito moi tu me
la mets sur les champsésées je la
reconnais pas du tout je peux pas dire
que c'est pas M Anderson toi resté sur
calendrier
calendri non maisi lui il croit qu'elle
va se balader sur les
ch avec une bouée frère non non non non
mais non c'est une démarche qu'elle a
initié depuis longtemps parce que depuis
qu'elle avait adhéré à la Fondation
briugit bardau parce que effectivement
le maquillage c'est souvent fait avec
des des animaux en tout cas test oui
elle a commencé comme ça elle avait dit
qu'elle
on verra combien de temps il tiendra
parce que si elle veut avoir des
contrats publicitaires des ch il qu'ou
plus beaucoup ça vendredelle cré la
tendance en faisant êre suiveuse à CR
buzp arrêtez de vous maquill les
filles lundi prochain Top là
pas vous trouvez que c'est
fantastique admirez faites pareil je
trouve que c'est formidable cette
liberté là et et de la soz libre mais
j'ai pas dit que j'avais cette liberté
là non vous trouvez ça vous applaudissez
faites pareil non mais dégage
Jean-Michel sort voilà sort non mais
c'est bon quoi le vendredi tu es nul le
jeudi aussi le mercredi le mardi alors
voilà et comme et comme Jean-Michel mer
ne connaît rien à la mode moi je te
garantis que justement il va y avoir des
créateurs
aujourd'hui vont justement S pour des
campagnes magistrale et mondial alors
que quand elle était justement toute
maquillée toute fardée avec un truc où
finalement elle peut pas faire elle peut
pas faire la différence par rapport à
une nana de 20 ans 25 ans je c'est vrai
c'est évident que quand on est belle on
a pas de contrat quand on est naturel
beaucoup qu'est-ce que tu allais dire là
oh là là oh là là fater tu as faill
fater
oh oh tu as faill dire alors alors sois
sincère on est belle tu as failli dire
quand on est moche tu as failli dire ça
tu as failli dire ça mais ah c'est pas
sorti ah là là Gill oh mais regarde-moi
dans les yeux regarde as regardé
complément d'enquête tu as regardé
complément d'enquête ou pas oui c'est
alors c'est pas le chroniqueur qui va
parler au chroniqueur c'est pas l'homme
qui va parler à l'homme c'est le
copilote qui va parler à la potiche
ferme ta gueule parce que moi au moins
je dis des choses que le personne a le
courage de dire moi j'ér pas ça mérite
pas la ftiste au copilote voilà ah bah
oui c'est catastrop non mais si tout le
monde est contre moi faut tout de su il
avait préparé en plus il préparé jé
ilait préparé ce B depuis 4 jours il a
sa
cquette ça mérite un T
[Applaudissements]
de quel po il avait préparé ça depuis 4
jour et en plus ça m'étonne pas
Jean-Michel mer parce qu'il a un
problème avec les femmes auudessus de 35
an j'ai un problème avec les femmes de
quand depuis qu depu 35 ans 4 ans mais
depuis quand j'ai un problème parce que
j'ai envie que tu a un problème
ok problème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
quoi tu dis qu'elle aura plus de contrat
tu dis qu'elle aura plus de contrat
parce qu'elle est pas maquillée ça fait
10 ans que tu es là tu as pas eu un
contrat tu te maquilles tous les soirs
donner un contrat ça ve rien dire ce que
tu dis ça mérite pas un
twi qui veut me défoncer là qui veut me
défonceras pas
besoinfon un peu comme certaines
personnes aujourd'hui tu as un problème
avec les femmes auudessus de 35 aucun
problème par que tuimes c'est des femmes
avec nickel quoi qu'elle est photoshopé
manucuré je vous avz un problème avec le
langage de vérité parce que c'est
magnifique vous allez continue vous
maquiller un pote franchement tu es
grotesque enlève ta casquette et ton t L
ouais c'est vrai ridicule enlèveè
d'habitude tu es nul mais là tu es
grotesque enlève e les mecs arrêtez
arrêtez d'attaquer
jean-michelichez tous tu sa même plus ce
non je pleure
[Rires]
connard en tout cas en tout cas on a pe
que vous un excellent comédien ah
franchement quel acteur une semaine qu'
se balade avec son sac et son non mais
c'est vrai ça fait une semaine qu'il se
balade avec fallit que je fasse ce soir
parce qu' on le rent c'est c'est c'est
un prê non
oui donc tu vas me dire que cette
connerie m'a coûé de l'osille 40 € non
mais je met
pas rend je suis plus à sa pr je vous
les rendi rien à oui je vous les
rendra rendez-moi ma femme je 40
€ 40 ball dans encore prendre SMS toi
fais gaffe tu sais quoi si j'étais toi
je me feris c'est des menaces là ou quoi
petit mais je dis pour disoi cl c'est
des menac parce que la dernière fois que
tu as fait ça j'ai reu des texos qui
défon j'étais toi j'étais je me feraai
tout petit petit petit
petit te rappelles de la BIB dans les
fugitifs oui par quand on est en Caval
on se fait tout
petit je te dis tu es en Caval fais-toi
tout petit petit petit petit petit
euh tu as quelque chose à ajouter ah bah
non là point j'en suis là je suis sous
terre non ça comment tu te mettrais en
note dans l'émission là pour l'instant
pour l'instant
sur combien sur
[Rires]
non mais dire que c'est vrai que j'ai
j'ai j'ai un truc sur toi sur le prime
des années 90 que m'a envoyé kakumbé je
peux te dire que tu vas fermer ta gueule
pendant très très longtemps inchallah je
gagne 240 millions ce
soir c'est le 20 décembre c'est le 20
décembre on sera en direct pour ce prime
moi je m'en fous je dis que j'ai la
chiasse je viens pas t'inquiète pas
alors je t'explique tu viendras tu
viendras j'ai un gros déjà fait un coup
comme ça une fois he non non j'ai un
gros bail sur toi quo le coup oui une
fois je suis venu ici un prime comme ça
une grande
d'ca très gentiment ramener une ex de
Tunisie que j'adorais dem sauf que chez
moi j'avais ma copine actuelle qui était
chez moi qui regarde la télévision qui
me voit en train de faire un bisou à une
ex mais moi j'ai changé mobilier ahah
oui oui ça je vouis pasur qui passe un
truc je suis énervé par rapport à ce
qu'il a dit sur Anderson défonce une
minute là j'ai pas envie vraent le
défoncer je sais pas si mérite mais non
mais en fait je trouve que tu nous dis
tu tu nous dis à Valérie à moi en gros
si vous êtes comme elle si vous avez
votre le courage qu'àamel Anderson en
fait venez pas maquiller fantastique
faites pareil
fantasti mon par je te demande juste un
truc meurs mais en
silence j'embrasse j'embrasse mon pote
mat Gonzalez qui est en championnat de
France de padol qui vient de m'écrire un
petit message qui nous regarde et frérot
déchire tout pour les championnats de
France et l'année prochaine j'espère
qu'on les fera ensemble je t'embrasse
fort on se retrouve dans un
instant